les
[Musique]
pour une fête de noël réussi il ya
d'abord un bon chanter noël
dès les premières notes quantique en
mains bénévoles et bénéficiaires assure
l'animation
les enfants eux sont bien trop occupés à
préparer leurs cartes de noël ont fait
ses voeux on exprime toute sa gratitude
et surtout ont fait preuve de créativité
je sens comme forme de dessin avec ma
soeur on fait des bottes carrées mais
s'attendent à recoller en sable c'est
n'importe quoi pour les enfants
et bien déjà de la concentration
[Musique]
des paillettes des coulées ont ces autos
et puis c'est le parentage
côté cuisine les bénévoles partagent
également de leur temps un repas de noël
traditionnels du pâté en peau des pois
d'angole sans oublier le boudin un repas
pour 300 personnes préparé avec beaucoup
d'amour
jal a fait avec jb c'est chez moi ce
matin depuis cinq ans on est là toute la
journée avec les familles qui sont
nombreuses et oui on fait des
connaissances qui on va faire de
l'amitié comme chaque année le secours
catholique de martinique organise son
repas de noël bénéficiaires bénévoles et
personnes isolées partage à chaque fonds
moment convivial un très bon moment ce
qui t'a plu aujourd'hui et cetera des
activités aussi c'est super c'est
agréable
sa maman d'un petit mois m'a davantage
habitués moment leur convient
convivialité il ça fait du bien de
retrouver de ce monde
[Musique]
un moment de joie et de partage auquel a
également pris part le chanteur jean
philippe marthély le temps d'une chanson
on ne se retrouve pas seul ce grand jour
de noël c'est celle a fêté noël c'est la
fête et ce sont des personnes avec qui
nous sommes en outre planer c'était tout
à fait normal de nos passions ensemble 7
jours 7 journées depuis plus de 30 ans
le secours catholique propose ce repas
de noël avec ses seize antennes sur
l'île
la délégation de martinique soutient
plus de 4000 bénéficiaires